Oh there,
it's October and that means at the
end of the month, Halloween is coming,
but when you think about it,
Halloween is kind of a weird holiday.
It's centered around the dead,
the monsters to creepy and things.
We generally find unpleasant.
We carve faces into pumpkins
and put candles and then
we decorate our houses and
more costumes relevant
to this holidays purpose.
It's the one time of year kids
can get candy from strangers.
What is going on here? Well,
for the origins of Halloween,
we'd have to go back to at least
700 BC to the Council of Europe,
specifically Ireland, Scotland, Wales,
and Gaul and the Celtic festival of
saw when or shop and he spelled s.
A. M. H. A. I. N. It's a Celtic word
and it has a very pronunciations.
Often I hear it pronounced saw one.
However,
with my understanding
of the Irish language,
I would personally pronounce it Shaaban.
Anyway,
sanguine or shoving occurred on the night
of October 31st and the early morning
of November 1st it was celebrated as a
middle between the RM equinox and the
winter solstice and it was celebrated
as the end of the harvest and as a pagan
religious holiday
and fires were lit up just
as they are today on Halloween.
Sometimes cows were started for their meat
for the winter and a festival is held.
Alcohol was consumed.
In fact,
it is notable to say that Merce
stories in Vulcan alcohol begin on saw.
I went in Irish mythology and legends.
However,
Shovin had a darker side to it.
The cat's believed in other worlds.
I was sort of their own and occasionally
these worlds were open between each
other. People venture into these
other worlds. After her death,
other times the living could
wander in and come out alive.
The mythology of these worlds
tends to vary from tried to try,
but some other worlds were very pleasant,
others were very dark.
These other worlds.
We're open to many times in legend,
but we're open specifically on two nights,
the night of Belton occurring and the
night before May 1st centered around the
living and sobbing occurring on the
night before November 1st it's centered
around the dead.
Shaaban was as somewhat dangerous night,
but they're always been not celebrate
with literacy and take precautions to
protect themselves as on this night dark
spirits to roam the countryside at the
barriers between the realm to the
living and the dead were broke.
These dark spirits were known as the ash.
She on fire served many
purposes and that mythology,
one of which was to
drive away these as she.
Some people would attempt to appease
these spirits by leaving food and drink
outside of their home for any of that
might pass by perhaps one origin of trick
or treating and others would attempt
to scare the spirits off by wearing
intimidating and flight for costume.
Another customs surviving these days
later when the Romans conquered modern,
they France,
which was in largely occupied by nerve
traditions mixed and became associated
with the Roman festival of Kimono
celebrating the Apple Harvest.
And the origin of apple bobbing and
even picked up on some Roman traditions
involving the debt which also held the
fires and drove off evil spirits and had
similar ideas of honoring the dead but
Roman traditions involving the dead
removed from February
to the end of October.
Eventually though Christianity spread of
the calcium a place many of their pagan
traditions, some Celtic Pagan holidays
were destroyed by the new religion.
Others were converted into
Christian celebrations.
Siteone is an oh off the bladder becoming
all hallows eve or holy evening in the
17 hundreds of Scottish began shorting
the phrase all hallows youth assembly
Halloween this weekend,
the partner,
the word for the holiday and
it's spread throughout Europe.
The three day religious period of all
hallow tie and Christianity and involved
in many customers are evolving the
civically around honoring the debt
specifically those are good
heart and the Christian faith.
It involved abstinence from me.
Lighting candles for the
deceased consecrating graders
was only water or milk
and many other traditions and customs
which varied and in fact still vary from
country to country. However,
in the Celtic nations,
the legend of the ashy and the traditions
of shower when we're not entirely lost
in many practices and traditions continued
and evolved into their modern forms
and Scotland. Children went
around them. It can these spirits,
but painted faces in costumes demanding
to be welcomed by strangers and to be
given treats or else they would
play a trick on their victims.
Eventually,
this became more common right Cole and
expected this trick or treating spread to
England and in America
in the 20th century,
they have tradition of carving
faces into vegetables. Specifically.
Turnips also continued to this time and
included eliminating them by placing
candles inside them related to the
legends of the word of the WISC or Jack of
the lantern, the legend of
jack-o-lantern. It's that of Stingy Jack.
When invited the devil to
have a drink with them.
He made a deal and a few mistakes,
but the apple,
which led to neither God nor the devil
wanting him in their realm upon his death,
the devil giving him a piece of coal tells
him to find his own health and as one
or the earth with a lid,
piece of call instead of carbs.
Fair enough.
Since the Celts card faces in the turnips,
which were lit similarly,
both to commemorate the legends
and the scare off Stingy Jack,
though when they came to America,
the Irish found the pumpkin made for a
much more decorative and affective fruit
for design.
Hence the creation of the Jack o lantern.
The large number of Irish immigrants
brought Halloween to the USA and Canada.
Where does a huge additional and
commercial event today becoming bigger?
There isn't perhaps the Celtic nations
from which it originated. However,
Halloween wasn't finished
there in the Victorian era.
Gothic literature assembly
came wildly popular.
Dark Tales of the undead core scenes
of the macabre and uncomfortable were
invented and thrilled to readers
across Europe and North America.
Stories like Bram Stoker's Dracula.
I trust that your journey from London
has been a happy one and that you will
enjoy your stain. My beautiful
man, you want a friend
Mary Shelley's Frankenstein,
you will rejoice to you that no disaster
has accompanied the commencements of an
enterprise which you have
regarded with such eel for boating
and the works of Edgar Allen Poe.
The red death devastated the country.
No pestilence ever been so fatal or so
hideous influenced Halloween's identity
much for it and the 20th century more
aspects of religious practice and
fascination with the gothic light
continue to influence Halloween until it
reached its great popularity in western
and even world cultures they'll be
getting as a pagan holiday and
later as a Christian holiday.
It is viewed now mostly as a time of fun
and a positive expression of a darker
side of the human mind and experience.
Some religious groups believe Halloween
to be an event of say 10 a ritual at the
majority of Christians believe neither
Halloween north saw when to be as such.
And many people,
even non Christians and
even non Westerners readily
celebrate the holidays with
mistake.
And so the event of Halloween was forge
of the course of 2,500 years by calts,
Romans, early and modern Europeans and
North Americans as well as other groups
influenced by both pagan and Christian
religious aspects as well as shadow
religion legend and chilling literature
and media such as the gothic tales from
the Victorian era as well as a whore
and books and films and imagination up
today. To recap, the wearing of costumes,
the decoration of houses and bonfires and
such were originally designed to scare
off the dark spirits and Celtic mythology
known as the s she trick or treating.
It comes from children pretending to be
these spirits by dressing up as I'm an
orthopedic Stuart.
The items left but these
spirits by threatening tricks
if they weren't received
bobbing for apples came
from Roman traditions.
Pumpkin carving dates back to the
legend of Jack of the lantern,
originally associated with a turnip until
the Irish found the Pumpkin in North
America.
Bonfires candles and even setting a place.
The Table For the CCE relatives on the
Snyder also originated from Catholic and
Christian religious
practices honoring the dead
already law all over. You're choosing to
celebrate it. Our warming work is zero.
Happy Halloween for more videos
on holidays and many other topics,
I'd invite a check out my channel.
Thank you for watching.
Okay.
Yeah.